ya hemos visto algunos vídeos sobre
evolución pero recordemos que la
evolución es el cambio de rasgos
hereditarios de una población a través
de las generaciones y muchas veces
escucharán decir a otras personas que la
evolución y la selección natural es lo
mismo pero quiero aclarar en este vídeo
que la selección natural es solamente un
mecanismo de la evolución y es del que
más se habla porque se considera un
mecanismo primario selección
natural y de lo que me gustaría
hablarles en este vídeo es de otro
mecanismo llamado deriva genética o
también conocida como deriva génica
entonces aquí tenemos la elección
natural y por acá voy a escribir deriva
génica
ok y hemos hecho muchos vídeos sobre
selección natural pero en resumen
podemos decir que consiste en que si
tenemos una variación en una población
en la que existen diferentes rasgos
hereditarios voy a dibujarlos de
diferentes colores aquí tenemos una
población y sus integrantes pueden ser
de color azul o pueden ser de color rosa
o tal vez existan en otra variación tal
vez también hay de color amarillo
entonces la selección natural nos dice
cuál de estos rasgos se adaptan mejor al
medio ambiente para que por lo tanto se
puedan reproducir entonces tal vez hay
algo especial sobre el vamos a decir el
azul eso permite que estos seres se
reproduzcan rápidamente o que no sean
atrapados tanto por los depredadores o
para que puedan acechar mejor a la presa
y entonces aún cuando son ligeramente
más favorecidos para reproducirse con el
tiempo por muchas generaciones
sus números crecerán y dominarán
mientras que para los otros rasgos será
más difícil sobrevivir
esa es la selección natural que en este
caso favorece al rasgo azul así que esto
se trata de los rasgos más aptos pero
miren la deriva génica también es un
cambio de rasgos hereditarios en una
población a través de las generaciones y
aquí no se trata de qué rasgo es el más
apto para él
ambiente sino más bien de los que
necesariamente sobrevive la deriva
génica en realidad se trata de cambios
cambios
cambios aleatorios
aleatorios
un buen ejemplo de eso sería esta imagen
en la que podemos ver cómo ocurre la
deriva génica aquí tenemos una pequeña
población de 10 conejos en la que está
presente el gen del color así que
tenemos dos versiones de ese gen o mejor
dicho dos alelos tenemos la versión b
mayúscula y la versión de minúscula y la
b mayúscula es la dominante este es un
ejemplo mendeliana entonces si tenemos
dos genes de minúscula es decir dos
alelos de los blancos es un conejo
blanco pero si tenemos dos alelos cafés
2b mayúscula el conejo es café y si
tenemos un heterocigotos el conejo es
café y como pueden ver existen
diferentes heterocigotos en esta pequeña
población pero si comparamos el número
de veces mayúscula con respecto a las de
minúsculas podemos ver que tenemos la
misma cantidad
entonces si elegimos un alelo aleatorio
de esta población podemos elegir tanto b
mayúscula como b minúscula
cuando el fenotipo es que hay más
conejos de color café y estos seis
conejos cafés tienen tanto b mayúscula
como minúscula pero ahora supongamos que
analizamos una población en la que
aunque haya conejos cafés y blancos no
hay ventaja es solo por casualidad por
pura casualidad aleatoria los cinco
conejitos de arriba son los que podrán
reproducirse y los cinco de abajo son
los que no se podrán reproducir y tal
vez piensen porque estos cinco sí bueno
yo no los escogí solo es un ejemplo
también podrían ser los cinco de abajo o
solamente estos dos podrían ser sólo
estos dos conejos blancos los que
podrían reproducirse pero todo esto es
pura casualidad o podría ser debido a
los rasgos que no están relacionados con
los alelos de los que hablamos pero
bueno desde el punto de vista de esos
alelos parece que es aleatorio entonces
esos cinco conejos se reproducen y en la
siguiente generación podemos tener esta
situación aleatoria
en la que miren la frecuencia del alelo
b mayúscula ha aumentado del 50% de los
alelos en la población al 70% y puede
existir otra casualidad aleatoria pero
no estoy diciendo que esto es lo que
siempre ocurre porque puede que ocurra
al revés aún cuando ocurrió la primera
selección aleatoria puede ser que ahora
este conejo blanco de pronto puede
reproducirse o tal vez no tal vez estos
dos conejos cafés que son homocigotos
por el rasgo dominante puedan
reproducirse y nuevamente no tiene nada
que ver con que sean más aptos entonces
se reproducen y repentinamente el alelo
blanco se ha ido por completo y eso es
porque el alelo blanco de alguna manera
hace que los conejos sean menos aptos o
tal vez les confiere alguna ventaja tal
vez desde otro punto de vista los
conejos blancos tenían un rasgo mejorado
pero por la casualidad aleatoria
desaparece de la población entonces la
idea general para
el comparar es que en la selección
natural el ambiente selecciona los
rasgos que son más favorables para la
reproducción mientras que en la deriva
génica son cambios aleatorios cambios
aleatorios en la reproducción de una
población ahora como pueden imaginar
aquí solo tenemos como ejemplo a 10
conejitos y lo que he descrito ocurre
más en poblaciones pequeñas entonces
ocurre más en poblaciones
pequeñas
y tenemos algunos vídeos de estadística
en khan academy por si quieren verlos la
probabilidad de que esto ocurra con 10
conejitos contra la probabilidad de lo
que ocurra con 10 millones de conejos es
muy diferente es más probable que la
deriva génica ocurre en una población
pequeña y de hecho los biólogos están
preocupados por las poblaciones pequeñas
específicamente por la deriva génica
porque por razones aleatorias puede
existir menor diversidad menor variación
en la población e incluso los rasgos
favorables pueden ser seleccionados
aleatoriamente ahora particularmente
existen dos tipos de derivas génicas muy
mencionadas debido a una reducción
significativa en una población una se
conoce como el efecto de cuello de
botella lo escribiré por aquí
efecto de cuello de botella
y el otro es el efecto fundador lo
pondré por acá efecto fundador
ok y las dos son ideas en las que
tenemos una reducción significativa de
la población por diferentes razones
miren el efecto de cuello de botella es
cuando tenemos un desastre o evento en
el que muere gran parte de la población
y solamente una pequeña parte sobrevive
se le llama cuello de botella porque
imaginen que aquí tenemos una botella
aquí tenemos una botella y adentro de
esta botella tenemos canicas de
diferentes colores entonces tenemos
algunas canicas amarillas a algunas de
color rosa y también tenemos no sé
algunas azules aquí tenemos algunas
canicas azules así que en la población
original tenemos mucha variación pero si
ahora las queremos sacar a todas de la
botella es decir si tal vez se ocurre
algún desastre bueno tal vez sólo dos
sobrevivirán vamos a suponer que
solamente sobreviven cuatro entonces
cuáles son las canicas que salen de la
botella
esto es solamente una metáfora
obviamente no estamos poniendo
poblaciones en botellas pero después del
desastre solo algunos sobreviven y tal
vez no contenga ningún rasgo que sea más
apto o deseable para el medio ambiente
pero recuerden que todo ocurre
aleatoriamente entonces por este
desastre sólo esto sobreviven así que
repentinamente ocurre una disminución
nociva no sólo de la población sino
también de la variación de la población
y muchos alelos tal vez se hayan
desaparecido así que esta es una forma
extrema de la deriva génica ok y el otro
ejemplo es el efecto fundador que es la
misma idea de que una población se hace
más pequeña pero el efecto fundador no
es por un desastre natural en este caso
bueno nuevamente supongamos que tenemos
diferentes alelos tenemos mucha
variación en esta población hay mucha
variación y supongamos que todos están
conviviendo en esta región
elvis están rodeados por montañas bueno
lo estoy inventando pero supongamos que
un par de estos personajes de color azul
un día estaban caminando y se separaron
del resto de la población
tal vez descubrieron algún pasaje
secreto en las montañas y comenzaron una
nueva población en otro lugar por eso se
conoce como efecto fundador porque estos
son los fundadores de la nueva población
y nuevamente eso ocurrió aleatoriamente
entonces ahora hay menor variación y son
una población más pequeña en este caso
todos son azules así que este es un
proceso de deriva génica en el que
varios alelos han desaparecido porque
aquí sólo tenemos una población pequeña
en donde todos son azules y como tenemos
una población tan pequeña es más
probable que ocurra más deriva génica
entonces es muy interesante pensar en
que la evolución y la selección natural
están relacionados pero recuerden que la
selección natural es solamente un
mecanismo de elebol
y que también tenemos a la deriva génica
que no se trata de seleccionar los
rasgos favorables sino que todo es
aleatorio